und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend die nachricht heute aus
london weckt schlimme erinnerungen an
den sommer 2017 als islamistische
terroristen auf der landen bridge
menschen überfuhren und später auf dem
market mit messern um sich starten heute
wieder die landen bridge wieder ein
attentäter mit messer und
sprengstoffattrappe die londoner polizei
spricht von einer terroristischen
attacke doch nähere hintergründe wurden
noch nicht bekanntgegeben yasin herr
land berichtet die unübersichtliche
szene wurde von passanten auf
handyvideos festgehalten es scheint dass
mehrere personen einen mann zu boden
gerungen haben
links im bild löst sich ein mann aus dem
handgemenge in der hand trägt er allem
anschein nach ein messer das er
möglicherweise dem verdächtigen
entrissen hat inzwischen kämpfen
herbeigeeilte polizisten mit diesem biss
ein beamter zwei schritte zurück tritt
auf ihn schießt und tödlich trifft
offensichtlich gab es hinweise darauf
dass der mann eine sprengstoffweste trug
am späteren nachmittag bestätigt der
chef der londoner anti-terror-einheit
dass sie die ereignisse als einen
vorfall mit terroristischem hintergrund
behandeln wir können bestätigen dass es
sich unserer einschätzung nach bei dem
gegenstand der und seinen körper
geschnallt war um eine attrappe handelt
am abend gab die polizei bekannt dass
zwei personen ihren verletzungen durch
messerstiche erlegen sind drei weitere
opfer werden in krankenhäusern behandelt
der tatort wurde weiträumig abgesperrt
menschen rannten davon in panik das ist
das erste mal in meinem leben dass ich
angst hatte jetzt sterben zu müssen
wir sagen dir eine frau auf einer bahre
weggetragen wurde
sie musste es wohl getroffen haben
wir sind ein restaurant gerannt jetzt
hat man uns gesagt dass wir gehen können
bemerkenswert wie auch schon bei
früheren ähnlichen vorfällen die
zivilcourage einiger beteiligter
dies hob auch londons bürgermeister
hervor
ich bin stolz darauf dass ich londoner
so verhalten natürlich haben die
einsatzkräfte auch außerordentlichen mut
gezeigt aber diese leute haben sich
unbewaffnet auf den verdächtigen
gestürzt
bei der london bridge attacke im juni
2017 kam acht opfer und drei attentäter
ums leben
diese erinnerung wurden nun wieder
wachgerufen wenn der hintergrund des
heutigen vorfalls noch nicht geklärt ist
auch in den niederlanden in den haag gab
es am abend einen vorfall mit einem
messer auf einer belebten einkaufsstraße
im zentrum der stadt stach ein mann um
sich
drei menschen wurden verletzt die
hintergründe sind aber noch gänzlich
unklar
die polizei spricht auch noch nicht von
terroristischen motive auch heute war
wieder ein fridays freitag ein tag der
großdemo von klimaschützern alleine in
deutschland gingen in über 500 städten
menschen auf die straße vor allem junge
menschen weltweit gab es in mehr als 150
ländern kundgebung die zwei des future
bewegung will druck machen
vor dem beginn der weltklimakonferenz
nächste woche in madrid
derweil hatte der bundesrat heute dem
klimaschutz paket der bundesregierung
zugestimmt wenn auch nur in teilen
die demonstranten lehnen die pläne aber
als ungenügend ab thomas reiter
berichtet als es dunkel wird dann
brandenburger tor steht luisa neubauer
auf der bühne wieder sind allein in
berlin zehntausende gekommen um zu
demonstrieren für die rettung des klimas
neubauer eine der organisatorinnen
könnte das als erfolg sehen tut sie
nicht
wir dachten wir zeigen eine zwei monate
hier stehen wir immer noch hier
nach 50 wachen und wir mussten lernen
dass ein koalitionsvertrag manchmal gar
nicht heiß tatenlosigkeit werfen sie der
regierung vor das klimapaket der reiche
bei weitem nicht aus ganz in der nähe im
bundesrat geht es an diesem vormittag um
das kleingedruckte dieses klimapakets
darum wer was zahlt die länder sind sich
einig sie weniger der bund mehr
das klimapaket ist richtig und wichtig
aber es sind noch nicht alle punkte
geklärt insbesondere nicht die
finanzfragen die natürlich basis sind
für ein funktionierendes klima paket
die länder fordern einstimmig dass sie
ausgleich erhalten für steuerausfälle
durch die senkung der mehrwertsteuer für
bahntickets
durch die erhöhung der pendlerpauschale
und bei den zuschüssen für energetisches
bauen
uneinig sind sie sich aber ob das reicht
den co2 preis den luftverschmutzer
bezahlen sollen hält baden württembergs
ministerpräsident für viel zu niedrig 10
euro haben keine lenkungswirkung also
selbst die wirtschaft möchte dass wir
solch ein lenkungsinstrument haben damit
sich geschäftsmodelle die co2 frei oder
co2 arm sind gegenüber geschäftsmodellen
die co2 emittieren
das ist ja der ganze witz um den es geht
diesen teil des klimapakets aber hat der
bundesrat heute verabschiedet wie auch
die vorgaben für co2 einsparungen und
erhöhte ticket preise fürs fliegen die
windenergie dagegen bleibt ein
streitpunkt eigentlich hängt dann jeder
ausstieg aus kohle und atomenergie und
das erreichen der ökostrom ziele zum
schutz des klimas
doch fünf bundesländer aus dem norden
schlagen heute alarm warnen vor einer
existenziellen krise durch überbordende
bürokratie
der ausbau von windenergie ist
dramatisch eingebrochen
in den zeiten wo wir aussteigen wollen
aus fossilen energien tun wir im moment
in deutschland alles dafür erneuerbare
an der stelle auch noch auszubremsen und
dem muss ein riegel vorgeschoben werden
wir brauchen übrigens überhaupt keine
bundesregelung zum thema abstand
regierung das können wir länder selbst
gemeint ist der plan dass windräder in
zukunft mindestens 1000 meter abstand zu
häusern haben sollen
das würde den ausbau noch schwieriger
machen das spd geführte
umweltministerium will den plan deshalb
kippen das unions geführte
wirtschaftsministerium beharrt darauf
für die klima protestierenden scheint es
wie ein beleg dass auch nach monaten des
protests die dinge sich nur langsam
bewegen
[Applaus]
langsam 2007 136 tage sind vergangen
seit der nicht eröffnung des
hauptstadtflughafens
der berliner tagesspiegel sonntag
genüsslich als nicht eröffnungs count up
und dabei rechnen die kollegen
großzügigerweise sogar erst ab dem
zweiten von jetzt insgesamt sieben
eröffnungstermin aber beim thema br sind
die berliner ehe längst in einem
gemütszustand jenseits von gut und böse
und die landesregierung wirkt da
inzwischen ziemlich ungeniert der ruf
ist ruiniert
und überhaupt in einer hauptstadt in der
es auch keine termine bei behörden gibt
oder lehrer für schulen oder
verlässlichen nahverkehr oder
vernünftige radwege braucht auch keinen
funktionierenden flughafen
doch jetzt wo wunder gibt es einen neuen
eröffnungstermin der 31 oktober 2020
diesmal ganz bestimmt und vielleicht
aber nur vielleicht wird es dann von
berlin aus sogar irgendwann eine
sinnvolle verkehrsanbindung an den
flughafen geben der bekanntlich jwd
liegt janz weit draußen aus berlin
kassen behrendt
br sind schon die koffer gepackt für den
härtetest der gepäck anlage es sieht
nach flughafen aus nicht mehr nach
baustelle so wird uns das terminal
präsentiert bei einem pressetermin
anfang dieser woche herrscht ein betrieb
wie ich ihn in den ganzen letzten jahren
bei besuchen auf der baustelle nicht
erlebt habt die flughafengesellschaft
gibt sich wirklich alle mühe und
journalisten klar zu machen dass es
jetzt wirklich losgehen wird mit dem br
heute nun wurde es konkret der
flughafenchef benennt den neuen
eröffnungstermin im kommenden jahr
wir werden am 31 oktober den
kommerziellen flugverkehr am ber im
neuen terminal aufnehmen und werden dann
in drei schritten bis zum 8 november von
tegel zum br umziehen wir sind sicher
dass sie öffnen
der ber eine leidensgeschichte 2006 der
spatenstich für das gemeinschaftsprojekt
von berlin brandenburg und dem bund nach
einer ersten verschiebung sollte 2012
eröffnet werden
weil das ist beschlossen dass es fertig
daraus wurde bekanntlich nichts
das chaos nahm seinen lauf immer wieder
wurden probleme unterschätzt die größten
der brandschutz abweichung von den
bauplänen und massenhaft falsch verlegte
kabel
die kosten stiegen von 2 auf
sechseinhalb milliarden euro aus
geplanten fünf wurden nun mindestens 14
jahre bauzeit entsprechend zurückhaltend
heute der aufsichtsratchef wir sind
nicht in einer situation wo man sich auf
lorbeeren ausruhen kommen sondern wir
haben defizite und wir haben eine menge
komplexen handlungsbedarf
trotzdem glauben wir wir schaffen das
für tegel sollte der start des br das
ende einläuten am 8 november 2020 soll
der letzte linienflug abheben danach
soll der innenstadt flughafen sechs
monate in bereitschaft bleiben
wir haben die aufgabe den flughafen so
weit im betrieb zu halten dass benutzbar
ist
allerdings wird der flughafen von der
flughafengesellschaft nicht mehr
betrieben das heißt wir haben dort keine
feuerwehr
wir haben dort keine betriebsblockade
werden die gebäude
bewachen am ber sollen die letzten
bauarbeiten ende frühjahr 2020 offiziell
beendet werden erst danach kann die
zuständige baubehörde den flughafen
freigeben und die finalen tests mit
tausenden komparsen beginnen es bleibt
ein wettlauf gegen die zeit
die chronik eines angekündigten
flughafens können sie können sie bei uns
auf heute.de auch noch mal nachsehen
von der ersten standortsuche in den
neunziger jahren bis heute
und jetzt erstmal die nachrichten von
heinz wolf der bundestag hat mit den
stimmen der großen koalition den
haushalt für das kommende jahr
beschlossen die ausgaben steigen im
vergleich zum laufenden jahr um rund 5,6
milliarden euro auf 362 milliarden euro
ein rekordwert
mehr geld fließt etwa in die bereiche
soziales klimaschutz verkehr und
verteidigung neue schulden sind aber
nicht vorgesehen
die zahl der arbeitslosen in deutschland
war im november auf dem niedrigsten
stand seit der wiedervereinigung der
arbeitsmarkt zeige sich auch in der
aktuellen konjunkturellen schwäche
weiterhin robust so die bundesagentur
für arbeit
demnach waren im november zwei millionen
180.000 menschen als arbeitslos
registriert das waren 6000 weniger als
vor einem jahr
die quote liegt bei 4,8 prozent im alter
gerät premierminister muskat wegen des
skandals um den mord an der journalistin
darf mit joana galizia immer weiter
unter druck
das europaparlament wird am montag eine
delegation zur beobachtung der
rechtsstaatlichkeit nach mal teil senden
vor zwei jahren wurde die journalistin
galizia opfer einer autobombe
zwar wurden drei verdächtige
festgenommen und angeklagt aber wer die
drahtzieher sind ist noch unklar
diese woche wurde der stabschef des
premierministers verhört wie auch der
tourismusminister trat er zurück
die journalistin galizia war auf beiden
korruption vor in brüssel haben sich die
eu-spitzen kommissionschef jean claude
juncker und ratspräsident donald tusk
aus ihren ämtern verabschiedet
zum abschluss gab juncker eine seiner
seltenen pressekonferenzen mit einem
ratschlag an seine nachfolgerin ursula
von der leyen
sie solle und auf europa aufpassen der
scheidende chef tus übergab seine
amtsgeschäfte und seine sitzungs glocke
offiziell an dem ehemaligen belgischen
ministerpräsidenten charme michelle die
neuen gegen spitzen treten dann am
sonntag ihre posten dann der schock über
den brutalen missbrauch von kindern im
westfälischen münster ist noch nicht
verdaut da wurde ein neuer fall bekannt
der möglicherweise eine noch weit
größere dimension hat im oktober gab es
in bergisch gladbach die erste festnahme
inzwischen sprechen ermittler bereits
von ca 20 beschuldigten die tausende
fotos und videos geteilt haben sollen
darunter wohl situierte familienvätern
wie die eigenen kinder missbrauchten
beziehungsweise anderen zu führten
es wurden gigantische datenmengen
gefunden die im geheimen chat gruppen
ausgetauscht wurden für die ermittler
einer mammutaufgabe die zudem psychisch
schwer erträglich ist
peter burger berichtet ihre augen sehen
in abgründe sie sehen was menschen
kindern antun können
300 mitarbeiter werden in
nordrhein-westfalen unmengen an bildern
und filmen aus die pädophile straftäter
bei ihren taten aufgenommen haben beim
missbrauch auf der eigenen kinder die
dann sogar anderen tätern angeboten
wurden
sie sind wirklich der meinung dass das
völlig in ordnung ist was sie tun dass
das was mit liebe und zuneigung zu tun
hat und dass das absolut kein
verwerfliches verhalten ist was sie an
den tag legen und das ist natürlich
absolut erschreckend
wir nennen nur ihre vornamen um sie vor
online beschimpfungen zu bewahren
ihre arbeit ist schwer genug die tat an
sich ist passiert die kann ich leider
nicht mehr ändern aber ich kann
vielleicht in zukunft ändern
in der zukunft ändern dass der täter
nicht weiter zugriff auf dieses kind hat
wenn man sich videos und bilder unter
diesem aspekt anschaut das gibt ein
letztendlich die motivation hinter der
arbeit und damit zurechtzukommen
der fall der in bergisch gladbach begann
hat enorme ausmaße bisher acht tatorte
nur in nrw dutzende verdächtige auch in
anderen bundesländern die gesamte
dimension nicht absehbar das material
ist viele tausend stunden lang die täter
meist unauffällige mitbürger die
sozialstruktur ist eigentlich das bild
aus der mitte der gesellschaft sind im
berufsleben sind sozial stabil sind
familienväter auch das erschreckt noch
mal zusätzlich macht aber nochmal
deutlich sexueller missbrauch von
kindern hat nichts mit status nichts mit
bildung nichts mit ihm zu tun die täter
kommunizieren über das internet im
darknet über handy chips in einer
adressverzeichnis fand sich laut
ermittlern 50.000 einträge in einem
forum 1800 mitglieder die sich oft dann
in kleineren gruppen treffen sie
verabreden sich zum geschäftsmäßigen
kindesmissbrauch
dort wird ganz konkret darüber
gesprochen wer welche missbrauch bereits
begangen hat hat er darüber bilder oder
videos kann man die austauschen und
natürlich werden auch verabredungen
getroffen in der analogen welt auch
unter dem hinweis bringt eine bring dein
kind mit ich bringe meins mit
und dann schauen wir mal wie es
weitergeht der jetzige fall kam erst
nach einem tipp von ermittlern aus
kanada ans licht denn dort und in den
usa ist die gesetzeslage ein anderer
dh dass dort provider verpflichtet sind
in diesen ländern ihre ihre daten auch
die von dritten eingestellten daten
dahingehend zu überprüfen ob
verdächtiges material hinblick auf
kinderpornografie vorhanden ist das ist
dann doch zwingen zu melden
eine solche gesetzliche regelung haben
wir in europa nicht das liegt einfach an
den europäischen datenschutz ein problem
ist der datenschutz ein anderes das
ungeheuerliche ausmaß dieser verbrechen
das dunkelfeld ist groß sagt der
bundesbeauftragte sexuelle gewalt gegen
mädchen und jungen hat eine riesen
dimension in deutschland und wir müssen
davon ausgehen dass in jeder schulklasse
ein bis zwei mädchen und jungen sind die
von sexuellen übergriffen und sexueller
gewalt betroffen sind
die ermittler sehen und hören den
missbrauch verstörende eindrücke jeden
tag seit wochen schon manchen wird zu
viel
sie bekommen hilfe von psychologen wenn
sie die bilder nicht mehr ertragen
können
seit wochen gibt es im irak heftige
proteste vor allem junge menschen
demonstrieren gegen die regierung die
sie für die grassierende korruption im
land verantwortlich machen
die polizei ist gegen die demonstranten
immer wieder mit extremer härte
vorgegangen mehr als 300 menschen haben
dadurch schon ihr leben verloren
gestern war ein besonders blutiger tag
mit fast 50 toten und hunderten
verletzten
der irakische regierungschef hatten aber
offenbar erkannt dass er sich im amt
nicht halten kann
zumal ihn die schiitische geistlichkeit
des landes den rückhalt entzogen hat er
kündigte heute seinen rücktritt an
susanna santina und christina cards
berichten
der tahrir platz in bagdad am abend die
freude bei tausenden menschen ist
riesengroß
die demonstranten haben ein wichtiges
ziel erreicht der ministerpräsident hat
seinen rücktritt angekündigt
schon seit dem nachmittag hatten sie
sich hier versammelt freudentränen nach
fast zwei monaten protesten doch den
meisten reicht es nicht
sie müssen alle gehen rufen sie sie sind
diebe heute sind wir iraker sehr
glücklich weil abtun macht die
zurücktreten wird aber das kann nur ein
erster schritt sein das gesamte
parlament muss weg sie sind
verantwortlich für dieses blutbad
der rücktritt des ministerpräsidenten
kam nach einem besonders blutigen tag
allein gestern wurden mehr als 40
demonstranten von sicherheitskräften
getötet 400 sind es mittlerweile
insgesamt jeden tag massen beerdigungen
und verzweifelte angehörige auf den
straßen
es sind vor allem die jungen iraker die
wütend sind und seit vielen wochen
protestieren weil sie sich von der
regierung um ihre zukunft betrogen
fühlen
perspektivlosigkeit und korruption
anprangern das harte vorgehen der
sicherheitskräfte vor allem in den
letzten tagen hat den
ministerpräsidenten nun wohl sein amt
gekostet
ich glaube die situation wird erst
einmal instabiler wir haben das letzte
mal gesehen dass es im irak bis zu einem
jahr dauern kann bis überhaupt eine neue
regierung gebildet wird wenn jetzt der
ministerpräsident zurückgetreten ist
dann kommt alles darauf an ob die
regierung und ihrer institutionen stabil
bleiben der irak aber ist in aufruhr im
irakischen fernsehen ließ abdel macht
die heute verkünden er wolle verhindern
dass das land weiter um gewalt und chaos
abgleitet
und auch dass er der aufforderung des
geistlichen als ist anni folge leisten
der einflussreiche schiitische prediger
hatte heute eine neue regierung
gefordert die iraner kontrollieren weite
teile der regierung in bagdad sie
kontrollieren
teile der sicherheitskräfte viele
milizen und besonders die polizei in
bagdad wird nichts passieren ohne dass
die iraner das genehmigen
viele demonstranten lehnen eben diesen
einfluss irans ab auch heute nach der
rücktrittsankündigung des
ministerpräsidenten gingen die proteste
und ausschreitungen in vielen teilen des
landes weiter
und jetzt nochmal heinz zunächst mit
wirtschaft die autobranche arbeitet dann
grundlegenden veränderungen etwa bei der
entwicklung alternativer antriebe und es
geht auch um arbeitsplätze in dieser für
die deutsche wirtschaft besonders
wichtigen branche wenn heute gab es
neuigkeiten von daimler daimler kündigt
einen massiven stellenabbau an wie
andere aus der branche auch sehen die
stuttgarter aus der krise offenbar nur
einen ausweg den radikalen sparkurs die
fetten jahre der autoindustrie sind
vorbei diese woche kommen die
hiobsbotschaften schlag auf schlag die
aktuellste von daimler mindestens 10.000
stellen weltweit fallen weg audi
streicht 9500 jobs vw hat schon
zehntausende stellen gestrichen legt
noch einmal nach mit weiteren 7000 und
bei bmw werden viele leiharbeiter gehen
müssen bittere bilanz die branche
kündigt allein dieses jahr einen abbau
von 50.000 stellen an immerhin wie audi
will auch daimler auf betriebsbedingte
kündigungen zumindest deutschlandweit
erstmal verzichten
frei werdende stellen sollen nicht
nachbesetzt die altersteilzeit
ausgeweitet werden
daimler schaufelt geld frei die
entwicklung sauberer antriebe und die
digitalisierung verschlingen
jahren die deutschen autobauer stehen
dabei besonders unter druck
jahrelang haben sie fast ausschließlich
auf den verbrenner gesetzt experten
gehen davon aus dass noch deutlich mehr
stellen wegfallen könnten zumal auch
zulieferer wie bosch schon massives
sparen angekündigt haben die mobilitäts
wende es nun endgültig bei deutschlands
schlüsselindustrie angekommen ballaballa
vielen dank bundeswirtschaftsminister
altmaier will die wettbewerbsfähigkeit
der industrie verbessern
in seiner industrie strategie 2030
fordert der cdu-politiker steuerliche
entlastungen und eine deckelung der
sozialversicherungsbeiträge
außerdem müsse die bundesregierung in
mehr bereichen als bislang prüfen dürfen
ob ausländische unternehmen anteile an
deutschen firmen kaufen können
notfalls müsse sich der staat befristet
an firmen beteiligen
in der fußball-bundesliga hat am abend
der dreizehnte spieltag begonnen
schalke führt kurz vor schluss gegen
union berlin 2 zu 1 die gesellschaft für
deutsche sprache in wiesbaden hat heute
das wort des jahres 2009 10 bekannt
gegeben es ist respekt rente
das wort bezieht sich auf die geplante
einführung einer grundrente für menschen
die 35 jahre lang erwerbstätig waren und
dennoch nicht von ihrer rente leben
können
auf den plätzen zwei und drei landeten
roller chaos und freude sv future
klimawandel ist auch eines der themen
nach denen die forschungsgruppe wahlen
die bundesbürger fürs neue
politbarometer befragt hat und das
präsentiert ihn jetzt antje pieper
guten abend bekommen zum politbarometer
streit um köpfe und profile in mehreren
parteien zugleich die spd ringt mit sich
selbst um die richtige führung die afg
steht abermals am scheideweg wird er
extrem rechte flügel an einfluss
gewinnen
bei der cdu ist der vorhergesagte sturm
auf die spitze ausgeblieben annegret
kramp karrenbauer konnte ihren kritikern
auf dem parteitag vorerst den wind aus
den segeln nehmen
schauen wir genauer auf die vorsitzende
der cdu wird ak ihre partei erfolgreich
in die zukunft führen
18 prozent der deutschen meinen ja knapp
drei viertel erwarten das nicht etwas
positiver aber auch mehrheitlich
skeptisch bewerten dass die anhänger von
cdu und csu
32 prozent sagen ja 62 prozent sind der
meinung dass annegret kramp karrenbauer
nicht dazu in der lage ist
wie wird die cdu chefin in einer reihe
mit anderen spitzenpolitikern der union
durch die eigene anhängerschaft
eingeschätzt auf einer skala von plus 5
bis minus 5 bewerten die unionsanhänger
angela merkel mit 3,0 markus söder mit
22 jens spahn und friedrich merz liegen
mit 1,8 und 1,7 etwa gleichauf
deutlich schwächer wird eine gerät kramp
karrenbauer gesehen 1,0 werte die auch
in unsere top ten einfließen war so in
die bewertung der zehn wichtigsten
politiker nach sympathie und leistung
durch alle befragten auf der skala von
plus fünf bis minus fünf landet annegret
kramp karrenbauer mit minus 0,5 auf dem
letzten platz wenn auch verbessert im
vergleich zum letzten mal auf der neuen
horst seehofer unverändert
k1 davor christian lindner etwas
verbessert 0,2 siebter neu dabei
friedrich merz 0,3 platz sechs auch neu
eingestiegen iren sparen ebenfalls 0,3
auf der 5 markus söder leicht verbessert
0,5 vor ihm heiko maas etwas
verschlechtert 0,5 die drei urlaub
scholz verschlechtert 0,7 platz 2 robert
habeck verschlechtert 1,1 ganz von
angela merkel auch verschlechtert 1,2
von den köpfen zu den parteien wenn am
nächsten sonntag wirklich bundestagswahl
wäre kämen cdu/csu unverändert auf 27
prozent die spd auf 13 minus 1 die fdp
auf 14 prozent unverändert die fdp
ebenfalls unverändert 7 noch die linke
konstant zehn prozent wird die grüne +1
kämen auf 23 prozent der stimmen
als einziges zweierbündnis hätte schwarz
grün eine mehrheit für grün rot rot
würde es wenn auch knapp nicht reichen
mit welchen vorsitzenden die spd in die
zukunft geht haben die parteimitglieder
basisdemokratisch entscheiden können in
einem monatelangen uhr bei verfahren
morgen abend gibt's das ergebnis der
stichwahl
wir haben die spd-anhänger nach ihrem
gewünschten doppel gefragt 38 prozent
sind für olaf scholz und klara geywitz
norbert walter borjans und saskia esken
finden bei 22 prozent zustimmung die
meisten spd-anhänger 40 prozent haben
sich in der führungsfrage jedoch kein
urteil erlaubt
an diesem wochenende stellt auch die afg
ihre weichen auf dem parteitag in
braunschweig wählen die delegierten die
parteispitze neu das ergebnis wird auch
aufschluss darüber geben welches lager
die oberhand hat das gemäßigtere oder
das extreme vor dem richtungsstreit
haben wir gefragt wie weit
rechtsextremes gedankengut in der afg
verbreitet ist
39 prozent meinen sehr weit 41 prozent
sagen weit nicht so weit verbreitet
sagen 15 2 prozent geht davon aus dass
rechtsextremes gedankengut in der afg
gar nicht verbreitet ist eine deutliche
mehrheit der deutschen 65 prozent macht
sich große sorgen wegen des klimawandels
die freude ist for future bewegung
mobilisierte heute wieder zehntausende
zum protest trotz nasskaltem
novemberwetter dass die bundesregierung
zu viel in sachen klimaschutz tut meinen
13 prozent 24 prozent finden den einsatz
gerade richtig
die regierung tue zu wenig meint eine
mehrheit von 60 prozent
ein großer teil der deutschen 41 prozent
findet aber auch dass das thema
klimawandel zur zeit zu präsent ist für
32 prozent ist es gerade richtig so und
für etwa jeden vierten geht es zu wenig
um den klimawandel
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
und auf heute.de wie die repräsentativen
umfragen der forschungsgruppe wahlen
zustande kommen informationen zur
methodik und zu den qualitätsstandards
finden sie unter politbarometer zdf de
vielen dank für ihr interesse das
nächste politbarometer gibt es am
freitag den 13
dezember nach dem wetter geht's hier
weiter mit der heute show viel spaß
dabei einen entspannten freitagabend und
einen schönen ersten advent auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer es hat in
den letzten zwei monaten mehr geregnet
als normal im oktober und november
aber die bodenfeuchte ist noch viel zu
gering also in den tiefen zwischen der
oberfläche und zwei meter tiefer sie
hier sehen sie das blau eingezeichnet
ist bedeutet nasser boden aber dann
haben wir den sommer 2018 da war es viel
zu trocken aber auch im sommer 2009 10
jetzt hat es geregnet in osnabrück und
die bodenfeuchte ist vorangekommen
also da er bis 1 meter tiefe haben wir
genügend feuchtigkeit darunter ist es zu
trocken dann muss es noch viel regnet
ganz anders sieht das aber auch in
dreslers im osten da ist es noch viel
trockener also dürfe bis im prinzip bis
zwei meter tiefe auch hier müsste es
noch weiterhin regnen drei monate regen
die könnten wir gut gebrauchen damit das
grundwasser endlich gefüllt wird kein
regen in sicht dafür frost heute nacht
zwischen null und minus vier grad ein
bisschen milder im nordwesten
ja und dazu noch ein paar schneeschauern
den mittelgebirgen auch an den alpen
haben wir noch regen und schnee die
schneefallgrenze sinkt hier langsam
weiter ab es kann in der nacht sehr
glatt werden
morgen dann positive temperaturen und
das heißt auch freundliches wetter
norddeutschland da wird es dann zum
beispiel ein bisschen stärker bewölkt
sein von der nordsee bis zum erzgebirge
vielleicht gibt es dann im norden noch
einen regenschauer
auch im östlichen bayern oder in bayern
selbst haben wir die stärkere bewölkung
aber im westen und auch im nordwesten
sieht es freundlicher aus und die
temperaturen erreichen im osten so etwa
1 bis 6 grad im westen nordwesten darauf
auf sieben oder acht grad ja es bleibt
kühl in den nächsten tagen und vor allen
dingen am sonntag wird es wohl im
südwesten schnee und schneeregen geben
auch in der nächsten woche im norden
vielleicht mal ein regenschauer im süden
ein schneeschauer
ich wünschen noch einen schönen abend
und machen sie's gut